dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly zsolnai-fehér
this one is going to be absolutely
amazing this piece of work is aimed to
help a machine build a better
understanding of images and 3d geometry
imagine that we have a large database
with these geometries and images and we
can search and compare them with
arbitrary inputs and outputs what does
this mean exactly for instance it can
handle a text input such as School Bus
and automatically retrieve 3d models
sketches and images that depict these
kinds of objects this is great but we
said that it supports arbitrary inputs
and outputs which means that we can use
the 3d geometry of a chair as an input
and obtain other similar looking chairs
from the database
this technique is so crazy it can even
take a sketch as an input and provide
excellent quality outputs we can even
give it a heat map of the input and
expect quite reasonable results
typically these images and 3d geometries
contain a lot of information and to be
able to compare which is similar to
which we have to compress this
information into a more concise
description this description offers a
common ground for comparisons we like to
call these embedding techniques here you
can see an example of a 2d visualization
of such an embedding of world classes
the retrieval from the database happens
by compressing the user provided input
and putting it into this space and
fetching the results that are the
closest to it in this embedding before
the emergence of powerful learning
algorithms these embeddings were
typically done by hand but now we have
these deep neural networks that are able
to automatically create solutions for us
that are in some sense optimal meaning
that according to a set of rules it will
always do better than we would by hand
we get better results by going to sleep
and leaving the computer on overnight
then we would have working all night
using the finest algorithms from 10
years ago isn't this incredible the
interesting thing is that here we are
able to do this for several different
representations
for instance a piece of 3d geometry or
2d color image is being embedded into
the very same vector space opening up
the possibility of doing these amazing
comparisons between completely different
representations the results speak for
themselves this is another great
testament to the power of convolutional
neural networks and as you can see the
rate of progress in AI and machine
learning research is absolutely stunning
also big thumbs up for the observant
fellow scholars out there who noticed
the new outro music and some other minor
changes in the series if you are among
those people you can consider yourself a
hardcore to minute papers scholar
high-five thanks for watching and for
your generous support
now see you next time
[Music]
you